streit um die masken wie hilft der mund-
und nasenschutz gegen die krise und
brauchen wir eine masken pflicht
der kampf um arbeitsplätze fast 500.000
betriebe in deutschland haben schon
jetzt kurzarbeitergeld beantragt
und das lange warten auf die heimreise
allein in neuseeland sitzen wegen corona
etwa 10.000 deutsche fest
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers einen guten abend
hinein wir freuen uns dass sie dabei
sind heute um 7 und wir geben ihnen
jetzt den überblick über die
nachrichtenlage und da beginnen wir mit
einer diskussion die jetzt auch in
deutschland voll läuft sollte jeder in
der öffentlichkeit eine atemmaske
getragen um andere zu schützen vor dem
virus
andere länder machen das bereits vor
auch bei uns gibt es immer mehr experten
die so einen schutz empfehlen das ganz
große problem bleibt aber nicht nur in
deutschland es gibt viel zu wenige
masten und selbst die die sie ganz
dringend bräuchten bekommen sie nur
schwer oder gar nicht david sauer
berichtet masken tücher oder auch schals
hauptsache mund und nase sind bedeckt ab
kommender woche ist das pflicht in jena
als erste stadt in deutschland in
geschäften und im öffentlichen
nahverkehr zum beispiel wir gehen den
zweiten schritt wir haben gesehen wie
erfolgreich wir mit unseren strengen
maßnahmen für reiserückkehrer waren und
jetzt wollen wir dafür sorgen dass das
virus innerhalb der stadt nicht
weitergegeben würden damit das gelingt
setzt oberbürgermeister nitsche auf die
gemeinschaft deswegen bitten wir um
mitarbeit nicht selbst für euch und
andere ein aufruf der elena überwiegend
gut ankommt ich finds gut denn wir
wollen sie nicht noch mehr haben in
extra schutz ist es auch nicht
zumindest wenn man damit der
verbreiterung in vielen asiatischen
ländern gehört der mundschutz quasi zum
alltag
österreich hat die pflicht gestern
angeordnet und auch im bund werden
forderungen danach lauter ich halte die
maßnahme für sinnvoll wenn wie gesagt
ist auch alle menschen tun und es wäre
dann eine gute ergänzung wenn wir das
kontaktverbot irgendwann aufheben können
um dann weitere infektionszahlen niedrig
zu halten
davon hält der bundesgesundheitsminister
der zeit nichts und setzt auf
freiwilligkeit hinter jetzigen lage sehe
ich keine notwendigkeit zu einer
verpflichtung nehmen aber im war eine
bereitschaft zur solidarität
absolute priorität habe jetzt dass der
medizinische bereich dass ärztinnen und
pfleger genug masken bekämen die
begriffe gehen dabei auf durcheinander
das eine ist so genannter mund
nasenschutz selbst gemacht oder als
einfache op masken der schützt vor allem
andere atemschutzmasken mit
partikelfiltern schützen auch die träger
sie sollten den medizinischen bereich
überlassen bleiben denn dort werden sie
dringend benötigt und zwar weltweit 40
millionen stück pro woche brauche sein
land sagt frankreichs präsident makro
schließlich sind sie einmal artikel um
aus der abhängigkeit von china zu kommen
soll auch dort die industrie mit
staatlichen milliardenhilfen ihre
produktionskapazitäten schnell ausbauen
und jetzt der moment in der sendung in
dem wir alle auf die aktuellen zahlen in
deutschland schauen und wie sie sich
entwickeln die johns hopkins universität
zählt 68.000 180 infizierte 682 menschen
sind gestorben das ist der stand vor
einer halben stunde im moment verdoppelt
sich die zahl der infizierten etwa alle
sechs tage
die bundesregierung sagt wenn wir es
schaffen dass sie sich erst alle zehn
tage verdoppeln dann wäre das bereits
ein fortschritt
ein rechenbeispiel starten wir bei heute
etwa 68.000 infizierten dann wären wir
bei der derzeitigen verdoppelung an
ostern bei circa 272.000 corona fällen
bei einer verdoppelung erst alle zehn
tage dagegen verliefen die kurve
deutlich flacher ostern legen wir dann
bei etwa 163.000 infizierten
das sind die daten die am ende
entscheidend werden bei der frage wie
kommen wir wieder aus alledem heraus wie
wird der kampf gegen das virus so
erfolgreich dass das land wieder zu
normalem leben zurück kam
es gibt aber auch noch andere antworten
und da kommt jetzt auch in deutschland
verstärkt eine methode ins spiel die
selbst fragen aufwirft die ortung und
identifizierung von infizierten und
deren kontakten mit hilfe von handydaten
die politik diskutiert über vor und
nachteile daniel pontzen die nutzung von
smartphones zur eindämmung der pandemie
in singapur etwa wurde das bereits
erfolgreich praktiziert als jens spahn
letzte woche ähnliches für deutschland
wollte gab es widerstand der justiz
ministerin durch sparen investiert diese
debatte muss geführt werden
meine positionierung dazu ist glaube ich
deutlich geworden ich weiß aber
gleichzeitig auch dass es nur geht wenn
es einen breiten gesellschaftlichen
rückhalt hat nun arbeiten fraunhofer und
robert koch institut an einer
datenschutz verträglichen variante einer
freiwillig genutzten apps diese app gibt
jedem handy eine anonyme
identifikationsnummer der bluetooth
kennen sich die handys im abstand von
zwei metern gegenseitig auf beiden
handys wird die nummer des anderen für
zwei wochen gespeichert wird nun jemand
positiv getestet sendet der dies an
einen zentralen server gesamt der liste
derer die zuvor in reichweite waren die
würden dann alle per push nachricht
informiert sie müssten sich dann testen
lassen und in quarantäne begeben
es würden also keine bewegungsprofile
entstehen sondern nur anonyme
kontaktlisten bei einer solchen variante
gebe es auch ihre zustimmung wenn diese
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind ich glaube
dann sahen wir eine große akzeptanz und
eine große bereitschaft antreffen diese
app sich auf zulagen das wäre auch nötig
denn nur wenn sehr viele die app nutzen
erfüllt sie den erhofften zweck
zustimmung auch von gewöhnlich
skeptischer seite weil die nutzung
freiwillig wäre leute zu zwingen apps zu
installieren sie dann auch noch zu
zwingen
die handys mitzunehmen und den akku
aufzuladen alles das ist nicht
vorstellbar
das heißt man muss die bürger und bürger
davon überzeugen dass sie bestimmte
daten zum nutzen aller miteinander
teilen das wäre bei der variante auch
über bluetooth der fall weil die daten
dezentral gespeichert werden und weil
eine anonymität gesichert ist ob eine
solche app technisch reibungslos
funktioniert müssen die entwickler
das fraunhofer institut erklärte es sei
zuversichtlich in den nächsten wochen
eine solche lösung zu präsentieren
besonders gefährlich ist das virus ja
für alte und kranke menschen umso
türkischer dass es sich jetzt auch in
immer mehr pflegeheimen ausbreitet nach
niedersachsen bayern und baden
württemberg ist jetzt auch ein
seniorenheim in nordrhein westfalen
betroffen in paderborn haben sich 43
pfleger und bewohner mit dem corona
virus angesteckt 2 85 jährige mit
vorerkrankungen starben hier an den
folgen der infektion
das virus stellt das leben auf den kopf
regeln gelten nicht mehr neue regeln
gilt es streng zu beachten für jeden
eine herausforderung noch mehr für alle
die sowieso schon besonderen schutz
brauchen menschen mit geistigen und
körperlichen behinderungen etwa die
pandemie erfasst auch ihr leben
besondere schutz pläne für sie gibt es
aber nicht dort ferber berichtet in
diesem haus in köln chorweiler von 24
menschen mit geistiger behinderung 14
davon sind dann corona erkrankt eine 49
jährige bewohnerin ist verstorben
eine pandemie dass es den bewohnern
schwer zu erklären
viele müssen in ihrem zimmer bleiben
isolations gründen
wir sind die einzigen bezugspersonen die
es gerade gibt aber wir sind reduziert
auf den kontakt in schutzkleidung auch
mitarbeiter sind erkrankt und alltag
gibt es ohnehin nicht mehr werkstätten
sind geschlossen ausflüge und besuche
gestrichen das gilt für fast alle heime
auch für solche ohne corona erkrankte
menschen mit behinderung zählen zur
risikogruppe weil viele mit
vorerkrankungen zu tun haben in ihrem
umfeld leben sie auch mit anderen
risikopersonen zusammen zusammen nicht
nur hier in der wohnstätte mit anderen
menschen mit behinderung es gibt auch
viele menschen die auch noch bei ihren
eltern leben wo die eltern inzwischen
auch ein gewisses alter haben corona
bringt wohnheime für menschen mit
betreuungsbedarf an die grenzen
auch für psychisch erkrankte wie dieses
dortmunder heim
niemand hier ist mit corona infiziert
aber der geregelter alltag fehlt die
werkstatt ist tabu infektionsschutz eine
herausforderung für alle die menschen
haben weiterhin einen anspruch auf
betreuung und auch auf berufliche
bildung das in der daran nichts dass die
werkstatt jetzt wenn nicht mehr betreten
werden kann es gibt auch menschen für
die eben diese störung des lebensalltags
dann eine große krise auslöst und die
das dann auch nicht akzeptieren können
keine angehörigen mehr zu besuch
begegnungen nur auf distanz für bewohner
von betreuungseinrichtungen ist das oft
schwer verständlich und immer schwer
erträglich und jetzt der kampf der
wirtschaft in dieser krise mit enormen
folgen für millionen von arbeitnehmern
in deutschland
heute gab es zunächst mal neue
arbeitsmarktzahlen und die sehen so aus
im märz zwei millionen 335.000 menschen
ohne job 60.000 weniger als im februar
die quote bei 5,1 prozent diese zahlen
aber zeigen die lage vor dem ausbruch
der krise also vor dem stillstand
sie werden sich deutlich verschlechtern
in den kommenden monaten und um
arbeitsplätze erst mal zu retten haben
bis jetzt schon fast 500.000 betriebe
kurzarbeit beantragt mehr von ihrer
schüler automobilzulieferer sind krisen
gewöhnt aber diese krise hat für
geschäftsführer händler eine neue
dimension das erste mal in der
geschichte steht die deutsche
autoproduktion still um den gerade noch
gesunden mittelständler zu retten musste
henzler knall auf fall alle 600
mitarbeiter in die kurzarbeit schicken
wir mussten unsere produktion auch
entsprechend zurückfahren da haben wir
das instrument kurzarbeit seit letzter
woche dann auch genutzt
das hilft uns damit unsere mitarbeiter
eben auch weiter im unternehmen
verbleiben können die mitarbeiter
bekommen jetzt von der arbeitsagentur 60
eltern 67 prozent ihres ausgefallenen
nettoeinkommens der mittelständler
stockt das kurzarbeitergeld noch auf
trotzdem ist die unsicherheit
dabei gab natürlich erstellen um ihren
arbeitsplatz weil sie wissen natürlich
nicht wie es weitergeht
wir wissen das natürlich und wann es zu
ende
allein in den letzten beiden wochen
haben 470.000 unternehmen kurzarbeit
beantragt es sei genug geld für alle da
verkündet arbeitsminister heil am mittag
aber aber zurzeit wird in deutschland
erstmals seit vielen jahren auch wieder
zunehmend deutlicher sagen wir können
nicht jeden arbeitsplatz garantieren
aber wir werden mit den mitteln die wir
haben um jeden arbeitsplatz kämpfen
der automobilzulieferer hewi kann sich
mit kurzarbeit über die nächsten wochen
retten aber ob der geschäftsführer
langfristig auf entlassungen verzichten
kann
völlig unklar ganz anderes thema in
dieser krise jetzt rund um den globus
läuft aktuell eine nie dagewesene
rückholaktion des auswärtigen amtes von
reiseveranstaltern und
fluggesellschaften
das ziel überall auf der welt
festsitzende deutsche nach hause holen
das hat inzwischen bei 183.000 touristen
studenten und solchen die im ausland
gearbeitet haben auch schon geklappt
tausende sitzen aber noch fest und für
sie wird es immer komplizierter weil
flughäfen und grenzen geschlossen sind
so warten zum beispiel in südafrika rund
7000 deutsche in thailand etwa 4000 und
in peru ungefähr 2000 und auch aus
neuseeland wollen über 10.000 deutsche
zurück dazu normen odenthal von der
großen weiten welt ist nicht mehr viel
geblieben ein hotelzimmer in auckland
zehn quadratmeter ein etagenbett seit
knapp einer woche sieht victoria kaum
was anderes mehr ausgangssperre
aber immerhin sie ist nicht ganz allein
victorias opa job endet verfrüht die
korona krise sorgt auch in neuseeland
für wirtschaftliche schwierigkeiten für
die gastfamilie wurde das kindermädchen
aus deutschland zu teuer
wir sind schon sehr sehr nervös und
dadurch machen wir eben auch weniger
weil wir immer irgendwie auf nachrichten
oder eine e-mail warten aber trotzdem
sind wir sehr dankbar dass wir noch ein
hotelzimmer gefunden haben und nicht wie
andere viele deutsche
rückflüge die die bundesregierung
versprochen hat aber nicht umsetzen kann
weil neuseeland dicht macht keine
einreise mehr und keine ausreise allein
10.000 deutsche sitzen fest
18.000 kilometer luftlinie eschborn zu
hause der tägliche videoanruf den alle
brauchen die tochter die eltern die
stimmung in der familie ist natürlich
angespannt und es bestimmt von kosmos
von auch sorge ein gefühl der
ungerechtigkeit und auch ein gefühl das
man einfach der neuseeländischen
regierung ausgeliefert ist weil die
entscheidet wann es ein wiedersehen gibt
ein echtes nicht nur per video ein
ganzes land und dessen wirtschaft
komplett lahmlegen nach italien macht
das jetzt auch spanien
die regierung sieht das als letztes
mittel um die immer weiter steigende
zahl von infizierten unter kontrolle zu
bringen
nirgendwo auf der welt gibt es im moment
so viele neue todesopfer operation
winterschlaf nennen das die
verantwortlichen in madrid und sie
ernten damit jetzt auch deutliche kritik
und die warnung viele firmen könnten aus
dem winterschlaf nie mehr erwachen
thomas walde mit mehr
mittag in madrid die regionalregierung
hat eine schweigeminute angeordnet für
die opfer des corona virus die straßen
sind noch lehrer als in den vortagen
nachdem spaniens regierung überraschend
verkündet hatte die wirtschaft lahm zu
legen nur lebensnotwendiges bleibt
geöffnet baustellen geschlossen
beschäftigte die von der neuen regelung
betroffen sind werden während ihrer
abwesenheit entlohnt sie werden weiter
bezahlt als hätten sie ganz normal ihre
arbeit gemacht
von carina mio laut regierung sollen
arbeitnehmer die fehlenden stunden
später nachholen wirtschaftsvertreter
kritisieren das als unternehmens feind
unternehmen müssen geschützt werden sie
schaffen arbeit güter dienstleistungen
und steuern
bisher unterstützte die opposition in
der korona krise die linie der regierung
damit ist es nun vorbei
was aber leider gang den montag sagte
uns die regierung es werde nicht daran
gedacht die wirtschaft vollständig zu
schließen das hat sie nicht eingehalten
das ist illoyal gegenüber der
wichtigsten oppositionspartei das
konferenzzentrum von madrid es soll bald
1400 corona patienten versorgen eine
pflegerin zeigt wie kollegen
plastiktüten verwenden um sich zu
schützen
spanien kämpft gegen materialmangel
steigende neuinfektionen die lähmung der
wirtschaft und gegen die schwindende
einheit in der krise und jetzt eine
etwas andere strategie schweden geht in
der korona krise einen sonderweg dort
gibt es keine strikten beschränkungen
weiterhin dürfen sich bis zu 50 menschen
treffen kindergärten und grundschulen
sind weiter offen restaurants kneipen
cafés auch schweden hat im moment
bezogen auf die bevölkerungszahl weniger
registrierte infizierte als deutschland
rund 4400 allerdings testet schweden
auch weniger und es gibt mittlerweile
auch stimmen die schwedens strategie als
riskantes spiel bezeichnen mit der
gesundheit der bevölkerung herrmann
bernd berichtet
frühling in stockholm die menschen zieht
es nach draußen das leben in schweden
geht ganz normal weiter
während der rest europa sich aus angst
vor dem virus abschottet ein
europäischer sonderweg nur ältere und
kranke sollen zu hause bleiben mehr home
office und mehr abstand draußen
der mann hinter dieser strategie ist
anders tech nel der oberste staatliche
epidemiologe von streng verboten hält er
wenig oder betrüger das bedeutet dass
wir in schweden zu einer reihe anderer
maßnahmen gegriffen haben wie mehr auf
zusammenarbeit und freiwilligkeit setzen
als in anderen ländern werden
das land will in schottland vermeiden
setzt aber auf das typisch schwedische
bekenntnis zur freiheit der bürger ein
liberaler weg in der krise leerer als
sonst sind die straßen schon aber
geschäfte cafes restaurants sind nach
wie vor geöffnet in der hoffnung dass
alle verantwortlich handeln und in der
öffentlichkeit abstand halten
ja ich fühle mich sicher es beruht viel
darauf dass ich das gefühl von panik nie
richtig eingestellt hat die sie die lage
bewerten und die maßnahmen bestimmen
handeln sehr überlegen es gibt gewisse
diskussionen ich persönlich finde es
doch ganz gut dass hier nicht die ganze
gesellschaft völlig herunter fahren
gleichzeitig habe ich angst dass es zu
naiv ist schweden bleibt bei seinem kurs
vorerst das sei effektiver als
drastische maßnahmen wie
schulschließungen meint anders tech nel
dessen vorgehen mit blick auf die
dramatische lage in anderen europäischen
ländern vor allem in akademischen
kreisen und der wirtschaft kritisiert
wird ob schäden sweg auf dauer
funktioniert werden die zahlen zeigen
einen vorteil hat das land es ist
außerhalb der städte sehr dünn besiedelt
das macht es leichter epidemien
einzudämmen
wann kann wieder fußball gespielt werden
und wie diese fragen hat heute die
deutsche fußball liga versucht zu klären
die dfl steht für die 36 profivereine
der ersten und zweiten liga ergebnis
vorerst soll der spielbetrieb bis zum
dreißigsten april unterbrochen bleiben
gemeinsam will man nach konzepten suchen
die saison bis spätestens ende juni
durchzuziehen und die wirtschaftlichen
folgen für finanzschwache vor
abzufedern die saison also verlängern
aber trotzdem fortsetzen markus haben in
frankfurt wie genau soll das aussehen ja
erst mal mit großem optimismus und dann
mit sehr guten krisen management durch
die dfl ich konnte gerade eben noch mit
dem boss christian seifert sprechen
der hat mir bestätigt sie wollen am
ersten mai wochenende wieder fußball
spielen und das ohne zuschauer ohne
zuschauer sie haben ein ganz klares
konzept die spieler sollen getestet
werden dann soll ohne zuschauer die
bundesliga saison zu ende gebracht
werden
nicht nur in der ersten liga auch in der
zweiten liga und erst danach soll wieder
mit zuschauern gespielt werden
wahrscheinlich sogar erst ende des
jahres aber diese saison soll zu ende
gebracht werden bis zum 30.06
und das sieht christian seifert auch
sehr optimistisch markus vielen dank wie
corona unsere gesellschaft verändert
darum geht es in einem zdf spezial mit
hanna zimmermann gleich nach und auch
online halten wir sie natürlich
jederzeit auf dem laufenden in der zdf-
heute- app unter anderem mit einem live
blog zur corona krise ja wir bauen
gerade unser halbes leben um bei der
arbeit zu hause nichts kann das echte
gemeinschaftserlebnis ersetzen aber wir
können zumindest nach alternativen
gucken einen film im kino geht gerade
nicht allein zu hause nur halb so gut
gute ideen sind also gefragt und
elisabeth schmidt hat einige gefunden
normalerweise stehen wiebke und johannes
thomsen hinter dieser tür im lot abbas
programmkino in hannover mittlerweile
stehen sie jeden abend vor einer
web-kamera kinotag funktioniert so die
beiden schlagen jeden tag einen film vor
den sich jeder zuschauer alleine im
streaming dienst anbietet beim letzten
montag waren wir über 60 leute die
parallel alle diesen film geguckt haben
das ist schon das ist abgefahren
die beiden diskutieren mit regisseuren
und die zuschauer chatten mit alles
gratis
angst davor ihre gäste an streaming
dienste zu verlieren haben die beiden
nicht
ich glaube dass die ganzen
streamingdienste das kino nicht kaputt
machen werden weil einfach die
kinoerfahrung das ausgehen das
zusammensitzen dass das knistern all
diese dinge
hast du nicht wenn du alleine vom vom
stream sitzt trotzdem not macht
erfinderisch online wie yoga virtuelle
partys mit freunden oder auch mensch
ärgere dich nicht passt so überbrücken
diese studenten aus göttingen die
kontakt beschränkungen
trotzdem raten psychologen jetzt nicht
zu stubenhocker werden was viele leute
immer vergessen bewegen lufteinlass und
frische luft sonnenschein rein lassen
sich mal ins fenster stellen ein
bisschen sport machen weil das eben auch
natürlich entsprechend glücks
botenstoffe aussendet und das gut für
körper und geist ist social des dancing
heißt eben nicht komplette isolation
frische luft und online treffen können
auch die stimmung heben
kaum jemand auf der straße momentan
diese ruhe kann man nutzen für einen
kleinen spaziergang zum beispiel ändert
no badeort im norden von wales die
ziegen hier leben sonst draußen im
grünen unter sich irgendjemand muss
ihnen erzählt haben dass es in der stadt
jetzt mindestens genau so ruhig ist eine
gute chance also sich mal eingehend
umzusehen und es scheint ihm zu gefallen
wetter gleich von besten terry 22 uhr
ist zeit für die kollegin marietta
slomka im heute-journal und morgen sind
wir wieder für sie da punkt 7
versprochen
für heute und vom ganzen team wo immer
es geht in allen ein angenehmer
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter es war schon
absehbar dass sich das hoch allmählich
verzieht und nun passiert es morgen wird
es sprecher hatte aber auf den süden
deutschlands kaum auswirkungen im norden
kommen aber regenwolken an
und das schon in der nacht zu sehen ist
hier auf der nacht karte viele wolken im
norden und es regnet etwas sonst ist es
sternenklar und die temperaturen gehen
empfindlich zurück minus 10 grad im
erzgebirge sonst leichter bis mäßiger
frost fast überall in deutschland
zwischen minus 1 und minus acht grad
zwei bis vier grad frostfrei ist es an
der nordsee morgen gibt es viel
sonnenschein vor allem in der südhälfte
deutschlands weiter nach norden hin sind
deutlich mehr wolken unterwegs und an
den küsten etwas regen und die
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte von 6
bis 10 grad im westen 11 im südwesten
sind es 12 grad
die kommenden tage am donnerstag gibt es
im norden noch etwas regen ansonsten
viel sonnenschein 7 bis 14 grad freitag
sieht eigentlich so ähnlich aus und
samstag wird es deutlich wärmer und
sonniger temperaturen steigen bis auf 17
grad an damit wünsche ich ihnen ein
schöner abend